you do your own stunts and you get
injured quite a bit you really go for it
there are some people that do their own
stunts but I get the sense you really go
for it when you do your stunts and
you've been injured yet it doesn't seem
to bother you that much because I've
heard that you you tolerate pain very
well you don't feel pain well I was
raised on a farm and my stepdad is
Icelandic and I think like and his mom
they have this kind of way of dealing
with life and bodies and pain that is
like you don't you just kind of ignore
it you get on with it and I was like I
grew up on horses I was always on a
horse and I threw like it was thrown off
many times the night broken ribs and you
know bleeding and scratches my god and
there was like sped up get on the horse
again like you know it's nothing to talk
about so I think my upbringing made me
kind of really quite tough and that's
something that is not oh no yeah I think
I mean I think it's okay for your
parents to teach some kind of stoicism
and I I don't want to step in here and
intervene in any way but I think if a
child falls off a horse and has broken
ribs and blood is shooting out the
correct response might not be get back
on that horse ride to town and get us
some chestnuts
well I don't know I just threw that in
for color yeah now you have a son oh
yeah okay what happens when he gets hurt
yeah ever had the experience where
you've tried to tell him yeah
walk it off pal yes how old is your son
he's 14
okay and I was I was here in LA I was
working on the script - what happened -
Monday mm-hmm
with the producers and director and the
writer and my son's been kind of
complaining that he had like area kind
of pain in his ears for a couple of days
but yeah yeah we just came in from New
York and I was like you know it's the
flight and you were in the pool in New
York and it's fine it's fine for three
days he was like kind of getting her
somewhere he's like crying I was like
don't cry come on it's just in your head
you know and then the producer said
maybe you should take him to a doctor
and then I was like fine okay so the
nanny took him to a doctor and then he
came back as a mom I have like full-on
ear infection yeah that was like so yeah
and then you know then I realized that I
it's something you know you I kind of
it's a bit blind to have this blind spot
in me because I was raised that way you
did feed him growing up right when he
was hungry you gave him food right yeah
literally like what is this food it's
all in your head go get we don't Ethan
this I gave you a chestnut a year ago
chestnut back in but I think you know
it's kind of you sometimes it's an
eye-opener yeah because it's easy to
just carry on with like the way you were
raised yes it becomes normality for you
and then you know so it's his party
trick now he's like one's my mom like I
had like burst eardrums and my mom
didn't take me to the doctor yeah sweet
elf is like his party tricks right right
he he needs a better party trick yeah
hey girls listen to this I once had an
ear infection
you